summer camp at a sanatorium where rest
is mandatory has long been a family
tradition in Ukraine for Michaela who
lost his arm before he was captured in
mariopul it's an essential Escape
you don't understand what it's like to
return from captivity first you are
happy but soon I was worried that I
would become like a third child for my
wife to care for
the sanatorium or traditional Health
Center offers medical treatment and
counseling but for the family the real
medicine is being together the same is
true for Constantine and Galina who
struggle to communicate after he was
released from captivity
I want you to be alone the memories are
very hard because we lost a lot of young
men friends were killed in front of me I
thought that I wouldn't tell anyone like
my father did after fighting in World
War II but then I realized I can't keep
it inside because it will become even
worse my partner supported me we are
together all this time
dozens of families who were captured by
Russian forces at the asov style steel
plant in mariopo last year are
recovering here far away from the front
line and Rocket attacks families find
some peace here for more than a century
people have traveled to the sanatoriums
of truska vets to rest and recover now
these treatments offer the kind of
healing many ukrainians need with a
sharp increase in domestic violence
since the War Began organizers hope
these camps can help to prevent abuse
this is a new and bitter experience for
Ukraine other countries have had similar
experiences the young men return after
killing the enemy but the aggression
remains when they come here they must be
ready to accept help the important thing
is we should not ignore this problem
Ukraine needs to better prepare Society
for how to deal with soldiers returning
from war to prevent a search in mental
health problems and abuse stop fasting
Al Jazeera tuscarvets West Ukraine